okay so we will take that we are going
to look at the next lemma specification
lemma which will come up with Lindy
stock and in the afternoon talk and
perhaps other times and so this part of
it is is a kind of non-constructive
lower bond part of my talk and but it
gives one motivation or or it gives you
one motivation for understanding
specification lemma so let's go back to
dep three circuit lower bounds so with
all the PPS c & p pz we achieved a small
improvement very very tiny improvement
although it is satisfying that we are
tight lower bond for parity but beyond
that so the achievement is extremely
small and and perhaps there are deeper
reasons why why why this approach may
not work but but I want to show that
that that the kind of lower bones we
want out of the type 2 to the N minus
little offer and if we can achieve such
lower bounds for dep three circuits that
will show certain problems cannot be
computed by linear size series parallel
circuits
so that may be one of the nearest goes
we may have okay and so they are there
no progress except for a very very tiny
improvement and oh and I want to give an
argument that shows that a random degree
two polynomial GF 2 polynomial requires
size 2 to the N minus little office it
is somewhat al Haq and counting argument
and it will not get us anywhere at this
point we haven't been go beyond that
random argument I've beyond that
counting argument but but at least it
gives you shows you the power of four
specification ok so that's that's one
way to look at it
so the goal is to show that a
low-complexity function requires largest
okay and
so the low complexity here turns out to
be the run a degree two polynomial
simple counting will not achieve such a
straightforward counting will not
achieve such a lower bound and and so we
are going to show slightly more careful
argument which Rahul has exploited to
prove similar bounds in other cases okay
a similar non-constructive bombs okay so
let's assume that
so we have a balanced function so that
Ezra so so that has roughly equal number
of zeros and ones and we have a circuit
size of 2 to the N minus little o of n
by using the top down argument we can
show that that a KC that one depth to
sub circuit accepts to to the little off
and many many of the ones so look at the
function f so look at its inverse and
set the set of inputs that produce 11 k
CNF must capture at least due to the
little o of n of them while rejecting
all the zeros so what we are going to do
is that we take a degree degree to G of
two random polynomial and argue that
with high probability as such a
polynomial cannot capture that many ones
that the Kasyanov cannot capture many
ones of this so degree two polynomial ok
solar so let's do the argument in the
following way so we so let's assume the
circuit is computing the function f and
the subcircuit is capturing a two to the
little of and many chin puts i need so
look at the case enf it has the solution
space of size 2 to the little o of N and
and we look at the VC dimension of this
space so think of the satisfying
assignments of the case enf has a system
of sets and the system of set sells a
large size 2 to the little o of n I and
therefore it must have large VC
dimension and and so let DB the VC
dimension and through through standard
calculations we can show that DS at
least so 2 to the little o so d is at
least little often
over some log factors so so that means
we have D variables assume without loss
of generality these are the first d
variables these D variables are
shattered Oh shattered in all possible
ways by the subsets of F inverse of 1 so
we are going to select ok I'm going to
go back and forth between satisfying
assignments as assignments and subsets
ok so let's select 2 to the D
assignments some okay FM f inverse of 1
such that in the first two d variables
you will get all possible combinations
among these are two to the D assignments
and and write the remaining coordinate
as as functions of the first d variables
so for each setting of the D variables
select one satisfying assignment and
write the remaining variables as a as a
function of the first division you can
do that always and in fact you can do
that as a degree D polynomial degree DGF
2.9 because this input once you fix the
setting of the D variables and you are
selecting a particular satisfying
assignment and that and once that
assignment is set you can so so so you
can write so you can write the bits as a
function of the first e inputs so what
you got is the set D Sub F of 2 to the D
sighs so think of it as a so Dean Saudi
variables as input and n minus D
variables are output and these output
variables are governed as polynomials of
dignity so you're each of the pis is a
coordinate that tells you what the value
of like XD plus 1 is so you've got an X
which is why followed by a bunch of
stuff and so X so 1 through X of d is y
sub 1 through X Y Saudi and then the
rest of the bells hpi is just telling
you one bit
Yeah right so HP I'd yeah yeah think of
it as a following input-output you have
d variables as input and you have n
minus three variables are output so each
output variable can be expressed as a
function of the Dean puts more than so
without loss of generality we can think
of pisa by as a multi-linear soda greedy
GF 2 polynomial every boolean function
can be coded by such poem so this so far
what I am saying is playing a kind of
simple facts so so there's no magic here
and i am creating i don't know what they
said about this set is and i do what i
do know is that there are there are room
so r 2 to the di2 to the d inputs such
that the first 2d coordinates are
completely shattered so it is degree g
just because it is multilinear and it
depends on there yeah basically depends
only on d variables and oh and you only
have right so you only have 2 to the D
vectors you selected and those vectors
only differ yeah they differ in the D
variables in the first two variables so
you can view the later variables as as
functions of the first two variables so
one thing is that we selected this
subset D Sub F and the function f the
function f is constant on this set and
the case enf is also constant on this
set and and so so what we argue is that
that if you take a random degree two
polynomial such a polynomial is constant
on this kind of set with probability at
most so 2 to the minus T Square so let
me say the following way so you take
this setup for Saudi Saba is a
particular set of inputs and what is the
probability that a random degree two
polynomial is constant on the set of
inputs why why are using degree to as
opposed to degree gee I'm going to show
for a degree tube-ok degree two
polynomials require 2 to the N minus
little o of n size for dep three
subjects so the function I'm computing
is a degree two polynomial is always
stronger oh I see suppose the
polynomials have there are two different
types of G of two polynomials to the
greedy one corner and so yeah so so we
so we're going to look at degree but we
are going to look at the computation of
degree 2 polynomials by depth three
circuits with the bottom fan in K and we
are going to argue they require size 2
to the N minus little o of n so to make
the argument we are going to focus on
the case enf and we know that any
circuit that has smaller size must must
accept a large fraction of once of this
degree to polynomial and and I and as a
consequence or is it it has a nice
subset of things that it accepts and
that set is called D Sub F
and so what I am doing is that i am
going to Saudi sub F is self is
expressed in terms of polynomial
equations so i am going to eliminate so
i take my degree two polynomials i am
going to make it more explicit on the
set so let me put it this way and on
under set D Sub F the degree two
polynomial is constant and so I'm going
to eliminate all the variables except
the first d variables using the
equations I have
and make this polynomial as a degree d
polynomial or degree polynomial in 2d
variables and still should be constant
but a polynomial d variables is constant
only when it is either 0 or 1 because
there is a normal form for multi linear
polynomials so so the argument I am
going to make is that when you eliminate
variables from the degree two
polynomials using the set D Sub F that a
random polynomial is not likely to be
constant so the probability of that
being constant is no more than 2 to the
minus T Square and and so therefore so
so then we are going to multiply this
probability with the number of sets D
Sub F
so each case enf that accepts a large
enough for a large enough number of ones
of the random degree of polynomial leads
to this nice set D Sub F okay and such a
nice set of that a random degree two
polynomial cannot be constant but there
are only so many kc & F's we can argue
or we need to deal with so we multiply
this probability with the number of kc &
F's and if the probe and if the product
is less than 1 so so we will have shown
that exists at least one degree two
polynomial that requires size 2 to the N
minus 22 office so that's overall
argument ok so far it's a trivial
counting argument the key here is that
proving it for degree two polynomials to
is fixed it does not depend on K so
that's where the magic comes in so
that's where we need kind of large more
powerful tools to prove this so a simple
counting simple arguments will not
suffice ok so let me
so let me give this proof for this a
proof for the last statement okay so so
just imagine a degree two polynomial and
assume it's random fix all its monomials
so there are some monomials that deal
that that truly consists of four terms
from from among the D variables so you
have the first d variables there's some
monomials that only consists of
variables from this set the rest of the
monomials consist of other variables so
fix all other monomers except those that
exclusively deal with the D variables so
replace each after last n minus 3
variables you so using those polynomial
equations so then you get some gigantic
polynomial of degree of degree D it's in
the D variables but you still haven't
fixed roughly d square many monomials
and each mono mela and each d square
such monomial it can be can be I can
have a coefficient 1 or 0 with equal
probability probability that this
polynomial will turn out to be a 0
polynomial or constant polynomial see
that most so 2 to the minus discs
so you are essentially reducing this
degree two polynomial on n variables to
be a polynomial and D variables and
without fixing some of the monomials and
and that's where you retain some control
and therefore you cannot make it
constant unless it's with a small
probability so this is a this has
nothing to do with circuit complexity
kind of clever argument using VC
dimension and and okay so now we need to
multiply this probability 2 to the minus
d square with the number of such sets D
Sub F the number of such sets can be
bounded by the number of kc n f
the number of Casey NFC is 2 to the n to
the K roughly
but whereas the probability here is 2 to
the minus d square so there is no
comparison between 2 to the n to the K
and 2 to the minus t square so we are
kind of lost already
so now comes to our rescue okay so this
is the first lower bond argument we
found for this Parsifal Emma although
it's not constructive so let me
introduce versification lemma here how
so basically specification ulema takes a
que CNF and shows that how it can be
represented by using a linear size a que
si NM so why and why did I say that they
are 2 to the n to the K many many k CNF
because casey NF may have roughly zen to
the km nek clauses so that's the set of
all possible k clauses and so you can
select any subset of them create a que
Siena so that's why you have roughly 2
to the N to the king so this Lamar says
that that there is a kind of normal form
for kc NF and that normal form turns out
to be quite useful in number of contexts
and i will talk more about it later and
the normal form is basically the
following thing that so you can write
this kc enough as as a union of linear
size kzns linear i mean the the
frequency of each variable is at most
roughly K to the K and this expression
can be done in sub exponential time so
key thing is that is not clear how to
write a que CNF as the union of linear
size cacia nerves in polynomial time but
if you allow sub exponential time it
seems we can do that one so that's what
specification
and true to the case seems like the
frequency of true to the case seems
necessary and the best we could get is
okay to that kid so now you can imagine
depth three circuits in the following
way so you have so the top gate is or
gate so then you have an gate followed
by a coyote followed by all gates or you
can look at the depth research as a
disjunction of kzns now what this is
saying is that replace each case enf
with a disjunction of smaller sized kzns
smaller means linear size of course so
the top or gate has a fan in something
like true to the epsilon and the rape
salon is arbitrarily small constant
voices so the size of these is small
because each only because of condition
to that says each literal doesn't occur
too many time right that's the thing
that says each of these is a small size
yeah so we control the frequency of the
literal variables yeah that's it that's
even a stronger a stronger bound and and
epsilon is yeah so does that's an
arbitrary constant and so if you now
look at the depth recirculate it can be
converted into your circuit where where
the top so we have two layers of the top
two layers are distinctions and the top
layer has fan in like 2 to the N minus
little o of n so the next layer of
disjunction has a fan enough to to the
epsilon n and then you have KC and
effort and then you have linear size
kzns so now you can squish this into a
depth three circuit okay since epsilon
is arbitrarily small so we still have 2
to the N minus little o of n a little of
an size circuit and where the bottom
level circuit sub circuits are linear
size k CN apps
now we can count now if you count the
number of linear size kzns that is
something like n choose K choose n so
you have n choose K clauses roughly kind
of ignoring the positive negative
literals and and then you choose
linearly many of them time so that's
roughly kind of n choose K choose n so
that's that that is n to the K to the
power n so that's roughly surtout to the
Big O of n log n so the number of cases
we need to deal with is is not dependent
on k strongly at this point and it's of
the form 2 to the n log N and whereas
the degree two polynomials set a degree
deeper two polynomials are given D
sufficiently large so d square I can
outweigh so n log in so therefore now
when you take the product of two to the
minus d square with with two to the N
log n so we come out ahead so we can
then prove that there are degree two
polynomials that must take size 2 to the
N minus root 11 so that little often
must I cannot be I cannot be I should be
after right size so square root should
be slightly more than square root
so this is a and this your first
introduction to specification lemma I
will not go over the proof of this and I
will give you a sketchy toward I'll give
you a sketch in the afternoon and so
just to give you an idea that a property
of kc n f can be so can be helpful to
prove lower bounds and there are many
other applications including right
showing certain directions exist and so
we'll talk about them later
so this is how we complete so basically
basically it's almost all degree two
polynomials require size 2 to the N
minus little offense as long as K is a
little off log the bound and K comes
because the because the variables occur
with frequency K to the K so that's
where K will play a role and so you can
get to manageable size up until k is a
little off locks
so that means we have a constant degree
and no matter what so the reason this is
somewhat technical is significant to the
following things if you look at so one
of the challenge questions for dec three
circuits it a dep three circuit lower
bond so the goal is to prove it two to
the N over to lower bond no matter what
the bottom felonies that breaks through
the barrier of the product x log of the
product or the bottom finding times log
off the top valley so you want to break
the dependency between a bottom fannin
and the top valley so so here that
polynomial here I mean there is some
analogy here that so degree two
polynomials are are sufficient for our
purposes and and we don't know how to
construct one such and the there may be
deep reasons why this may be hard and I
don't know
so obviously making it a more
constructive will be interesting and
making it fully construct finding a
finding a functioning NP that can be
represented as a degree two polynomial
that has this property that will that
will be very very interesting
power-one attention and use this
specification limit to go back and say
something about those polynomials be won
through BN minus D X on simplification
of them
I don't see how it would help
so we smells am no simplification will
help in any case the argument
yes if we know something that is
specific about p I so that will help
something constructive out p sub i that
will help and since we don't know how
this F inverse of 1 is distributed among
the case ENS I don't know how kind of
easy it would be to say something
positive something constructive oh but
lowering the degree itself may not be
sufficient
okay so the last part of this talk is
switching lemma this clearly is one of
the deepest results in circuit
complexity and and I assume okay so let
me just read the classical theorem or
lemma and so we have a case enf and
spars are otherwise c so important here
so we take a random restriction so so
random okay you can think of a
restriction as a mapping from the
variables 201 and start variable is
mapped to 0 then it's set to 0 if it's
map-21 it's set to 1 so that's
understanding if your variable is mapped
to star that is then then we call it
unset so you take a random restriction
so random means that this mapping is
random and with the P and unset
variables the star variables theorem
says that that that so the decision tree
of the formula of the case enf under
this random restriction has height more
than T is bounded by so the decision
tree falls exponentially so for example
you would like to take P to be 1 in 10 K
so 1 in 10 K fraction of the variables
are unset then 5pk will be half so then
you have 2 to the minus T probability
that the correspond that that the
restricted formula has a decision tree
complexity more than T so arm right what
is the value of this system plane will
be the same if you
this or sample less vertices but just on
the assignment to zero and one or it's a
bit it's really important that you
select this stock selection state again
so you want is it important that you
have a market in 23 White is 0-1 and
Stan so what happens if you have room
arkansas-little 1 & 0 and if you map
everything then of course we are talking
about the restricted formulas if you map
all the variables two constants then the
restricted former will be simpler so the
more variables you have unset so the
better so that so the stronger the
statement is who does the scene of if
you select less religious in the sample
or is really put a concern
so setting fewer variables is a good
thing so the remaining variables have
start variables it's a function of the
resulting function is a function of the
variables that are set to star so right
so star just as a way of saying don't
set that okay and you're only interested
in what's left over as a function of
those starters supposed to be friends
you don't set anybody for the fun for
the variable or exactly that's exactly
the same that effective okay so ya
better thing is unset so we're not doing
anything to that variable so that's what
start means okay so this is like we're
looking at so we will talk about
canonical so this is not minimum we can
constructively show that so we are going
to have a standard method for
constructing decision trees and in that
standard method that that that we are
unlikely to exceed the high tea
so so what's the value of this one so so
basically so you can so that means if
you have a small decision tree so that
means CNF complexity and the dnf
complexity are both small so you can
express it a small small width dnf are
small with CNF so so you can start with
AK CNF which which you need not
necessarily have a small width dnf but
once we apply the random destruction so
then with high probability it has a
small width as a dnf so then we can
combine so this can be used as a tool as
an inductive are to make an inductive
arguments on the depth of the circuit so
let's say we have a depth three circuit
pi sigma pipe for example so you take
the bottom sub circuit which is a CNF we
apply random restriction most likely it
will be a dnf for a small width then we
can take the depth at the top level gate
and the second level gate and combine
them into one single of one single
circuit are one single layer that will
give us a dnf of small weight so this is
a technique for reducing the depth of
the circuit after the random restriction
so then we can inducted allowed you on
the remaining security
so
I'm not going to say a lot more in say a
lot about switching lemma I assume in
this presentation I am assuming it's a
background material I'm going to say
something something what happened after
that work some extensions of it and
there are applications to lower bounds
and upper box so using switching lemma
as I was saying before one can prove
lower bonds of the form a two to the
square root n over 10 for parity for it
for computing parity okay bye depp three
circuits so this is a standard tool and
this I and more importantly using
switching lamai control for depth D
circuits pariet a computing parity takes
size 2 to the n to the 1 over d roughly
observing constants so the previous
argument i showed about satisfiable
decoding lemma makes the argument
somewhat title for for computing paraty
by deb three circuits so that's where
the satisfiability coding lamar was
somewhat helpful but otherwise this is
so this is the reigning truth or the
this is the most important thing we know
about dealing with AC 0 circuits so we
are motivated by ok where do we go from
here so we are motivated by the
following question can we come up with a
satisfiability algorithm for AC 0
circuits that has the right type of
savings savings that generalizes from
the case enf savings s'okay CNF has a
savings like 1 over K ok I know can we
so let's can we can we extend those
savings for constant of circuits so
that's the question and we show how to
extend a switching lemma to tackle that
adapter d circuits and come up with a
somewhat efficient satisfiability
algorithm that seemed to generalize a
PPS en ppsc not the constants but the
flavor of the argument
so we also proved strong correlation
lower bonds for parity so using the
switching lemma or the extended
switching lemma okay so so the key is
extending the switching llama to deal
with the classes of formulas rather than
a single case E and F so let me take you
through through through some definitions
before I get to that so we are dealing
with depth D circuits so let me use the
following parameterization so the number
of variables is n m is the number of
gates in the circuit so d is the depth
and you have layers of and or gates and
and let's let's let's say that M equals
CN c could be a function of n so that's
how I'm parameterizing it so the point
this parameterization useful when M is
linear C becomes more prominent and and
and that's the reason for the
parameterization or for now you can
think of it as a linear circuit but but
C can be viewed as a function of N and
and all the arguments generalize in that
case so let's look at even more special
circuits same class of circuits as
before but the bottom file name is
bounded back
and oh so this is the satisfiability
algorithm let me first make the
statement so we have a randomized
algorithm that succeeds with the
constant probability in finding a
satisfying assignment when there is one
and and it takes as input a circuit with
uh with n variables c and size on death
d and and and produces the
satisfiability algorithm and produces a
satisfying assignment with high
probability and where the savings is of
the form kind of ignore the d log.d
factor saudi lagdi term for now so
that's something we tried hard to get it
off it seems that's so so that may be
necessary so one way to think about it
is basically basically the savings is
one in log c to the power D minus 1 this
strictly generalizes the previous
algorithms in the format if you look at
the p pz algorithm that's one in k and
if you think about specification and if
you can improve the specification
constant to 2 2 to the K so the kind of
worst-case instance of kc NFR those when
you have frequencies of the variables
around 2 to the K so that means they
have size 2 to the K times n so if you
take see that so that means C is like a
2 to the K so log see is like a so one
in k kind of generalizes to one in log
see so that's the right that seems to be
the right generalization subject to our
state of understanding okay I'm there
the dependence on death and the
dependence on the depth seems to be like
when the depth is to like in the case of
kc enough so you have one in log see so
when the depth is three okay one in log
c square that seems to be the best known
dependence between between the depth and
size parameters and the satisfiability
savings significant improvements in this
one or further improvements in this one
will have significant consequences and
so that's the result and this
comes again from the switching lemma and
extender switching them may be worth
noting the this algorithm also to count
the number of sub science animals that
we r i p pz good not right by the way so
this result is independently is obtained
by johann true and i would like to
mention that and we both were working in
parallel it turns out and this is due to
russell myself and william our student
right so this can also count the number
of satisfying assignments in the same
time so the key i know i'm there by it
also shows so let me show you the next
argument so it also shows a strong
correlation bound and exponentially
strong correlation browned so this is
the definition of correlation between
functions and how likely they so they
agree with each other on a random input
and and and the correlation coefficient
can be defined to Q minus 1 and so we
are going to define correlation between
a function and a class of functions so
what's the closest function so to this
function f from the family and we assume
typically we assume that the class a
free is the bar is closed under
complementation so then the correlation
will be between zero on one and and so
we are going to show so the so 0
basically okay when the correlation is 0
means that the funk that the two
functions F and G can agree half the
time and disagree half the time so
that's a normalization so so the result
will show is that the correlation
between between parity and a circuit of
the type nmd G's is given by that part
so 2 to the minus mu times then mu is
the satisfiability savings that we
showed before and and it's a strong
exponential
so so this in exponential strongly
exponentially small correlation between
parity and unfunctional computer by such
circuits so so we can also count as
Holger said we can also count the number
of satisfying assignment in the same
time and
so um so even if you okay
so what can we say about the further
improvements and if you can improve so
let okay that log M should have been log
M over N okay so then you try to become
log see but but at of my name is very
very large M over N doesn't have much of
an impact and if we can improve the
exponent of the savings to be little off
d so using Williams using ryans
techniques we can show that so that so
that next play is not a subset of in c1
so we kind of almost reached the limits
of for the technology at this point we
need new ideas so either by improving
the satisfiability algorithm or some
other technique to to lower bounds so
that was the motivating factor for this
for this for this series of research can
we prove strong lower walls and depth
three circuits or depth D circuits in
general which will occur which will
imply so lower bounds unkind linear size
large depth circuits or NC one more
generally and and God satisfy both
algorithms and they proved strong
correlation a lower bounds but but the
real breakthrough is still not there and
whether it comes through satisfiability
improvement or some other some other
technique we don't know okay let me give
you a sketch of the proof and minutes
so what we are going to so if you go
back to the switching lemma what it says
is that once you apply a random
restriction very likely you will have a
small decision tree complexity
so of course there is a probability that
there is some probability exponentially
small but they are nevertheless there is
some probability that that the decision
tree maybe maybe a full length now
because how are we going to use this
random restriction type of argument
towards a better satisfiability
algorithm so we select a random
restriction so the way we do that in the
following way but we select the
variables or we select a random set of
variables of the right size to be set to
0 or 1 so that is of size n minus P and
P is the probability of not setting a
variable then we are going to look at
all possible possible assignments to
these variables so we are going to
explore all possible I sentiments that's
a 2 to the N minus P and many settings
and if you need such setting we have a
small small case en fr small KD enough
we can now we can then apply so we are
going to look at each such settings so
that means we have exponentially long
algorithm already and if the circuit
simplifies in each such setting ok we
can squish the next tool but has come up
with a smaller circuit of lower depth so
then we can record argue it so that's
the hope so we simplify the circuits I
know I know so then have a lower depth
so then and maintain the size and then
hope to contact the same argument so so
the problem is that we we don't we don't
necessarily get small decision tree
always and under there are many so we
have to content so we need to come so
let's take a depth three circuit as a
kind of running argument especially a pi
sigma pi circuit with bottom panel king
so if you get the induction goings we
need to take the bottom level dnf
convert that into a CNF so then we can
do the induction so when you apply
random restriction to the bottom level
sequence of K DNFs not all of them will
convert
2k cns some of them will still have
large decision tree complexity and we
need to kind of content with the
situation I know and there could be
correlations among the K DNFs and and so
what we are going to argue instead is
that rather than looking at a canonical
decision tree for one single case enf or
k dnf so we are going to look at a
canonical a decision tree for a sequence
of K DNFs or sequence of K cnips i'm
sure this long decision tree that that
works for all k CNF srk DNFs is not
necessarily that long so we apply so oh
we prove a result very similar to the
trance witching lama in flavor and in
quantitatively speaking and i know we so
we'll be able to so deal with a sequence
of k DNFs so before that let me
introduce some notation and oh and so
the idea is that so remember the
top-level argument I am saying that that
once you take the set of area but random
set of variables up and then instantiate
them so you would like to see some
simplicity so the resulting k dnf should
simplify should turn into a a decision
trees with a small small complexity but
that's not going to be completely true
so we are going to further refine the
space and within that restricted space
we can find simplicity so for that
reason so we're going to introduce this
notation so we say if we say a set of
functions partitions of space the
bouillon cube are provided the setup
ones of each of the functions so define
the partition
and and so let's call each pathway
region and each region is defined by the
by the set of one's of the corresponding
function and these functions GS will be
very simple so G silly to each G will be
a capital j which will be a que CNF and
a row which is a restriction so
restriction set some variable to zero
and one leaves other variables untouched
so we are going to find regions which
are defined by a simple function / like
a casey and i find a restriction and
within those regions we argue that that
the sequence of k dns can be simplified
so two circuits are equivalent within a
region if they are equal and restricted
to that to those inputs okay so this is
a long definition mouthful of a
definition but simply what it is saying
is that so you take a circuit see and I
know and we partition the we partition
the space of all inputs and within each
partition or region the circuits ii will
simplify to be C sub I C sub I should be
a lot simpler complaint to see so that's
that's the kind of writing we want to
that's a kind of simplification we want
so let me also introduce canonical
decision trees and so canonical decision
trees so you fix an order for the
clauses of the formula of the CNF and if
a clause is empty so then returns 0 and
if there are no clauses written one
otherwise take the next clause and query
the variables in that order and and then
restrict the formula and they repeat the
process
so this is just build akka akka bilder
cannot build their decision tree so
using some other and got the variables
and classes so similarly we can build a
canonical decision tree for a sequence
of for a sequence of kc and nerves or k
dns we do the same thing once you know
now so we build a canonical decision
tree for the first formula along each
path we restrict the remaining formulas
or basically at each leaf we restrict
the remaining formula and Undine
Whitaker's so the point is that towards
the very end so it so you so you have
leaves so these leaves fix particular
values for each of the formulas so
therefore the leaves are labeled by
tuples of zeros and ones one for each of
the formulas f so i think of this as a
joint decision tree for the sequence or
the set of formulas
so so what might happen is that once you
queried the closets have a particular
particular formula and then you try to
build the decision tree for the next
formula maybe that formula is already
simplified you don't need so you don't
need to query the process of that
formula ok so therefore we want to come
up with this notion whether a class
contributes variables to a path or not
so that a formula contributes variables
to a path along industry provided there
is a class of that formula that is
queried and if no clause is queried
because if no claws of a particular
formula is a query during a pap that
formula play no role along that path so
with that definition so let me talk
about the extender teaching them so what
extender switching Lama does is that
builds this canonical decision tree
shows convince the canonical decision
tree and shows such a canonical decision
trees after applying the random
restriction will not have a long length
so so we take a random restriction with
different parameters here and and the
combined decision tree or the joint
decision tree has a path of length
length longer than T ok weighted with
each F sub I contributes at least one
such node but one such variable along
the path is thirteen peak activity so
it's possible some formulas got
simplified so they're not clear along
the path we are focusing on those where
where every single formula is created so
this is very much similar to the
switching llamas in spirit and now and
we are building joint decision trees and
we are arguing with this modified
definition that so these trees need not
be too long
at all so doesn't depend on um different
formulas the rest of the trp but so we
are assuming that aah so you chew so
each formula is created but we have and
when we apply this then so this is a
assuming that every fi is involved when
we apply it at the next stage we're
going to have to do a Union bound over
all the clauses there are of subsets
that could have affected contribute to
it so what I could do some implicit
condition where T is at least him in
this right now but any wants to know
right so T has to be at least a variable
is creating
so things get simplified and certain
formulas may not be queried so therefore
you look at all subsets of formulas that
are being used and we are going to
multiply with that so T is large yeah
so I'm not going to show how we are
going to apply that but let me first
state the result and so this so this is
the result that is going to be useful
for for approving look for obtaining at
satisfiability algorithm and so we have
the sequence of KD a nurse and and what
the switching algorithm does is that
it's a it's a randomized logarithm that
succeeds with the constant probability
and I need partitions the space into
into regions where each region is
defined by AK CNF and the restriction
such that within the region the KD the
sequence of K DNFs can be expressed as a
sequence of kc n else
so right so I'm hiding lot of detail and
on the connection between this lemma on
the previous one but so this is
sufficient to show how we can obtain a
better satisfiability algorithm for dep
three circuits so then we can do a
similar
so this works as long as the size of the
circuit right so the size of the
partitioning is bounded by that bounded
by that number and and right of em plays
a role and so right
CFM is too large that will war when the
savings we obtain so so the savings is
and in 100 k that is offset by the size
of em and and that that's where the
dependence comes so let me show you how
to apply this for depth three circuits
so we have a depth three circuit so
think of it as pi sigma pi and our end
and that means at the bottom two levels
are a sequence of DNFs and i will come
up with a satisfiability algorithm that
achieves savings roughly one in log c
square so so we are going to apply
shoulders type of argument remember the
sigma pi's remember pi sigma pi circuit
is arbitrary circuit so there is no fan
in restriction to begin with so we apply
shoulder like argument to restrict
defining to be king and and so there is
some overhead at that overhead is
minimal so that's not going to and k is
going to be kind order logs and see is
the size of the circuit CN is the size
of the circuit basically order log see
seems to be the optimal value for K and
so we convert the circuit into bottom
fan in case our kids so that's the first
step so then we apply switching
algorithm where we partition the space
into into many regions so each reason is
essentially defined by K CNF and within
each region the sequence of K DNFs can
be expressed as a sequence of kc enough
now now we can take the defining k CNF
and the sequence of casein f which are
the result of our our input circuit and
write it a one big Casey enough and take
the top and gate kind of right as one
big case here now so within each yeah so
we can collapse the levels and then
attach the defining k CNF so that means
as long as that case enf is true that we
are computing the satisfiability for
that for the tree shion and so we write
everything as one single case you so
then apply the case at algorithm for
this case UNF so then we have so that
gives an overall savings of one in lok
SI square
so this is what so this is the ideal
thing you will expect so so let's say
that we apply random restriction with
parameter like p being one in one in k
so you syrian / k variables so then you
simplified everything from a KD n f to
york a CNF when you apply the algorithm
again then you get the savings of one in
KF + / k that's one in k square so
that's the best you can hope for a given
and that kind of technology we have can
hold we can deal with kc n + 1 k CNF at
a time so that's how we know how to do a
satisfiability algorithm and so this
achieves the basically almost the best
possible bound subject to kind of a
subject to improving k CNF
something exactly on Doc questions